guys movies cherry we're talking bad
lighting here we go all right so it's
Friday Friday gotta get down on Friday
and I just there as a family crossing
the street I just got back from the new
Marvel picture the new motion photo
event of the afternoon and Marvel garden
gardens of the gardens of the galaxy
guardians of the galaxy I haven't slept
up a whole lot these past few days um
guardians of the galaxy that's correct
the new film from Marvel Studios
directed by a guy I am quite fond of mr.
James Gunn uh this guy came from Troma
which as some of you know makes a very
low budget I some would say schlocky uh
you know b-movies be horror movies such
as the toxic avenger um he worked on he
wrote from Romeo and Juliet I think
terror firmer was he involved i'm not
sure but yeah so James Gunn uh is a
decision you know like I heard there
they got him to do this movie and I was
like okay that's interesting because
I've been worried about Marvel man I've
been concerned cuz like okay check this
out there was a time that was a time
when Marvel was like whoa okay you're
getting legit interesting filmmakers to
make your movies you got Kenneth Branagh
booth or you got Jon Favreau to do the
Iron Man films uh you got oh I'm
blanking on his name now and I can see
it I'm looking at it my eyeballs in my
brain uh Shane Black you know people
like that um and it seems like lately
they've run into some trouble I'm a
little concerned for our friends at
marble on I like Thor too but you know
they got a director for that movie who
has done a lot of TV a lot of Game of
Thrones suitable choice it makes sense
but on the other hand
it's switching to TV directors like that
is a little worrisome simply because
those are people who are more used to
you know falling in line with the sort
of studio and produce oriole bottom line
TV is much more of producers medium and
Marvel and Disney and you know all these
giant money corporations are in these
positions were now that stacks of chips
are really high and so taking risks is
kind of I don't know maybe a little more
scary than it was before so so this
movie from the start has interested me
um because I really liked James Gunn's
movies I love super slithers a lot of
fun and I was also really excited for it
because um you know I've been getting
battle fatigue as I'm sure many of you
who have watched this little whatever it
is no with a lot of the big you know
blockbuster action movies and stuff
they've kind of started to run together
for me and I find it harder to get
excited about them and what I liked
going into this movie was the fact that
they were branching out into some of
their more out their titles and doing
something that was a little more quirky
and and strange and funny they also took
a risk in this movie I Nicole Pearlman
is the other writing credit you'll see
and I did a little bit of reading on her
and it's cool because Marvel has their
first credited female screenwriter which
is awesome and I guess they came to her
um you know she's been kind of pushed
around by the system and you know gender
stereotyping and she I guess really
wanted to write some sci-fi and some
some you know comic book stuff and I
guess Marvel came to her and was like
here's a list of titles that you could
potentially right for us and she picked
guardians of the galaxy and they were
kind of like
and she was like yeah and they were like
okay and so I'm so yeah james gunn and
and Nicole Perlman are both the credited
on this script I think that's really
cool you know it's a cool team and you
know it's it's certainly a statement
that they're making with this and I'm a
little worried about Marvel because they
seem the news trickling out about their
upcoming lineup is a little alarming
because I go right you know is it's a
strong statement for a directorial
choice or even drew goddard I know the
Lighting's tear I'm so sorry um see I it
seems like they're having some trouble
with their there you know bottom line
right now but enough of that guardians
the galaxy how was the film you know
what man I quite enjoyed this movie I
don't I don't know necessarily if it's
like perfect but um it's a lot of fun
man and and the best stuff about it is
when that humor and that you know wit
and and that sort of james gunn miss is
is able to take hold the cast in this
movie is great Chris Pratt is a lot of
fun to watch I like Zoe Saldana I go
back and forth on her but I quite liked
her in this Bautista is great really
funny even even you know you get a
little bit of Vin Diesel in there not
not in your face but you know he's
really good Bradley Cooper's great
they're a great team together and even
though a lot of the time it seems like
they sort of don't belong together but
that's part of the fun of the creek and
also this ow and also the supporting
cast is really good I can't even name
them all but you've got some James Gunn
regulars I know his brothers in there I
know Michael Rooker's in there he's
great Peter Serafinowicz pops up john c
reilly pops up going close pops up
janeman han soo is in this Benicio del
Toro karen gillan for all you dr. Satan
fans out there ha it's dr. who uh
I rob zombie family odd there's always a
Rob Zombie vocal cameo and in James
Gunn's memories it seems and I was able
to pick it out this time unless it's not
him um so yeah this movie man what's the
best stuff about this movie to me is
like it is really kind of a
wonder-filled movie and I like that
Marvel is branching out more into their
sort of really science fictiony stuff
because this movie takes place on a
number of different planets and
different realms you're out in space a
lot there are these really gorgeous like
nebula formations and clouds of dust is
a very sort of sci-fi art you know
picturesque sort of a movie that was a
really horrible description but um yeah
so just the designs of everything are
gorgeous and I really appreciated seeing
it seems like they went to the trouble
to build a lot of sets or at least parts
of sets a lot of this Seth looked like
for the most part people were actually
in them and it was nice to see so many
practical effects so much makeup and
stuff like that and so many different
kinds of characters you know you get
certainly a sense for a very multi
cultural multi-species universe and
that's a neat place to go because you
know most the more movies take place
predominantly on earth or in a place
where most people are you know like be
human people it almost there elements
are you know it has that sort of flavor
of a very fast universe the way you know
like a gear moto Toro movie almost does
kind of like how Hellboy has this sort
of very vast universe or even men in
black and stuff like that not not so
much totally but you know it's it's got
humor and it's got a lot of different
cultures and designs and stuff like that
there are lot of different places and
that's that's part of what is so much
fun the effects are are mostly great I
mean you know it's an expensive movie
and not every shot is going to be
incredible but there's a lot of really
good effects especially on Rocket
Raccoon
and grew they are great you know those
one of those things people were like are
they gonna be able to bring that to life
yeah you're for the most part yeah this
is a bunch of of you know misfits
bandhan together which isn't a new
premise but it is cool that they decided
to at least play on the fact that all
these people are hurting in some way all
these people have their issues and
they're all at the end of the day these
sort of broken people who have all come
together so it doesn't it doesn't get
super like you know there's there's
still a balance between character stuff
and action but it does tip into the
character stuff and that's a lot of fun
it's nice to chew on you know I got
misty-eyed a couple times feeling
feeling for these people um you know and
so you'll like these people on the
villain is really evil I think it's also
cool to see Marvel branching out into
territory that is Italy somewhat
different from the general superhero
movie mold I mean there there is a fine
line there are definitely similarities
but it's nice to see some characters
that aren't by design technically
superheroes you know you have this sort
of band of misfit outlaws each of whom
has their own abilities in our own thing
they bring to a team the personal
struggles are different than just like
the strange lab accident happened but
now you know I'm alienated from the
world and and vigilante justice is
looked down upon and it's nice to see
five characters who are all dealing with
you no cracks and insecurities and
promise beyond that stuff you know these
are the things that have been informing
their lives and aren't a result of you
know
kind of superhero type accident so it's
nice to see them and just did that kind
of a territory of this movie does well
just to give Marvel the confidence or to
you know just bolster their confidence
in you know choosing more left-of-center
properties and you know continuing to
pick interesting writers and directors
for the project because ultimately
that's that's the charm and that's what
works about a lot of the Marvel stuff
when it works you know I'm feeling good
about this movie I like it would be cool
to go back I feel like to sort of see
what you catch on the second time and
maybe what things come out on the second
time and and I'm part of what I also
appreciate at least in the writing and
the directing of these characters
specifically is the fact that all the
humor and stuff comes from the
characters and who they are this there's
a lot of like a reoccurring joke sort of
about Chris Pratt keeps saying just
these things that people on earth or you
know humans would say and and people
keep not understanding that which which
is just sort of a neat little detail to
throw in there you know because we sort
of assume especially with Hollywood you
know cinema culture that everyone knows
what's American or what's you know in
this case human and they don't and it
keeps coming up and I think that's
really just just really cool if that's
part of the fun is there are so many
cool little details and little jokes
they put in and stuff like that and it
makes for at least as of now what I
think is probably one of Marvel's best
movies and probably when they're most
interesting it's not completely
revolutionary in terms of the fact that
it is still a Marvel movie like nu yeah
there are certain things you know we're
going to happen but it's really well
done and it's it's it's it's really well
done it's really well put together it's
really well orchestrated um and you know
it does have some surprises so uh yeah
definitely definitely check this movie
out man I saw it in 2d I imagined it
would look really good in 3d um so yeah
what did y'all think I mean I've never
read the comics so how did you think
they translated this to the big screen
are you happy are you not happy are you
happy about some things and not about
others why don't we should be more
middle ground as a society I feel like
you know cuz so much the internet ages
people going this is amazing or this is
shitty and it really is it ever truly
one of the other silly now let's talk
about this anyhow oh and tyler bates man
that that that the score the music is a
character as well in this movie and yeah
they've made a lot of musical films
lately and this movie has a lot of
personality when it comes to its music
and it's a big part of star-lord his
life you know it's in you know it's just
a sort of a recurring motif and it makes
the movie all the more fun it gives it
sort of a different vibe because we're
not we'd marvel movies generally don't
have a lot of you know flux between all
here's this you know song you know
here's hooked on a feeling and now
here's this thing by the Jackson 5 and
here's this and the actions good of
course it's Marvel movies uh-huh so ya
guardians of the galaxy I'm headed over
to ryans to talk about this now so I'm
gonna get going uh but you cool cats
have a lovely afternoon evening night
whatever time of day you're watching
this and until next time but shears deep
the expression not that television is it
that's good too but cheers
you